thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air
see now the law calls for a maximum fine
of $85,000 land as much as five years in
prison
what hay legal eagles it's time to think
like a lawyer today we are covering the
series finale of Seinfeld I was never a
huge Seinfeld fan so I haven't seen that
many episodes and I don't think I've
ever actually seen the finale what but
some of you legal eagles out there told
me that it involves some legal issues
and a trial so I'm really looking
forward to reviewing what happens in
this episode as always be sure to
comment in the form of an objection
which I will either sustain or overrule
and stick around until the end of the
video where i give the series finale for
seinfeld a grade for legal realism so
without further ado let's dig in to the
finale of Seinfeld okay so what has
happened in this episode so far which is
not legal per se but I think it sets up
the rest of this episode the gang
decides to go on a vacation in Paris NBC
gives them the use of their private jet
because they were screwing around in the
air the pilot had to do an emergency
landing in this very small town in
Massachusetts and so they're just kind
of walking around this random town
deciding what they're going to do next I
think this is where the legal stuff
kicks into gear nice day
another one right that's all out of the
car I'm gonna capture this alright so
I've got a carjacking you know what
don't you
so he's the the robber has his hand in
his pocket like there's a gun see the
great thing about robbing a fat guy is
it's an easy getaway
you know they can't really chase you
it's actually kind of crappy things to
say
[Laughter]
I guess because there are New Yorkers
they're not gonna help okay thanks
anyway they can't get another plane
right what's wrong with the plane we got
there just check-in is videotape
evidence all right I think I know where
this is going getting on there come on
let's get something to eat here in
sticks Ville all right all right there
okay why isn't the police officer
calling in for backup and chasing down
this guy who just committed a carjacking
here you'd think that if someone was
robbed at ostensibly gunpoint I mean we
didn't see a gun but the guy had his
hand in his pocket and kind of gesturing
it towards the the poor guy who was
being robbed and makes it seem like
there's a gun I mean that is armed
robbery that is grand larceny and in the
first degree and I mean that's a major
felony so I don't know why this police
officer is being so nonchalant about a
first-degree felony that has just
occurred and he's kind of letting the
bad guy get away here all right there
what you're under arrest under arrest
what article to 23-7 of the lakeland
county penal code what no no we didn't
do anything that's exactly right
the law requires you to help or assist
anyone in danger what it's reasonable to
do so no that is that's that's not a
thing it's called The Good Samaritan Law
okay this is this is really interesting
from my perspective so the writers of
the show are conflating a couple of
different things here first of all there
is such a thing as Good Samaritan laws a
Good Samaritan Law is an exception
two general responsibilities when you
choose to act to back up a little bit
further in American law generally you do
not have an obligation to help anyone
under any circumstances unless you
undertake some action and the law
imputes a duty to you so the classic
example in law school is if you see
someone drowning in a pool you are not
responsible for helping them out of the
pool
but if you choose to actually help them
get out of the pool where they're
drowning and you do so in a negligent
way well then you can be held
responsible for the damages that you
caused to this poor person that was
drowning even though you undertook to
save their life and so the general rule
is you do not have any kind of
obligation to help your fellow man and
as New Yorkers they're clearly
exercising that normal right now a Good
Samaritan law is an exception to that
rule that says if someone is in danger
or you undertake to help that person
where you wouldn't normally have an
obligation you are protected by law so
that they can't turn around and sue you
if you help them get out of a drowning
pool or you perform CPR on someone that
was drowning or you perform the Heimlich
maneuver normally without a Good
Samaritan law you might be liable for
negligently performing the Heimlich
maneuver or negligently performing CPR
but a Good Samaritan Law is sort of a
defense for good Samaritans who help out
okay so that's the first thing that's
what a Good Samaritan law actually is
now number two is that generally there
are no affirmative duties like this
police officer has said that there is
some law that says that you have to
undertake to actually help people now
there are a couple of exceptions to that
rule but let me see if they talk about
this so-called Good Samaritan Law in
more detail to get an idea of what
they're dealing with here Good Samaritan
crazy how would we want to help somebody
no that's what nuns and Red Cross
workers are for
ancient try very helpful
all right um excuse me hi could you tell
me what kind of offices oh yeah let's
see about the law well they just passed
it last year
ah it's modeled after the French law
okay I heard the island after Princess
Diana was killed and all those
photographers were just standing around
yeah you're the first ones to be
arrested on it probably in the whole
country okay so it's not often enforced
that makes sense pay the fine or
something and get the hell out of here
it's not that easy so you now the law
calls for a maximum fine of $85,000 why
and as much as five years in prison what
what no no no no we have to be in
California next week where we start a TV
show California
oh gosh I don't think so yeah my guess
is you're gonna be prosecuted get
yourselves a good lawyer okay all right
let's unpack this a little bit here so
what they're talking about here is not
actually a good Samaritan Law it's
actually what's called a duty to
rescuing law as I said before normally
you don't have a duty to rescue people
you are free to walk by an injured
person without having to help and a Good
Samaritan Law is the thing that actually
gives you a defense if something goes
wrong when you choose to help someone
but a duty to rescue does impute a duty
on you as a passerby to actually
intervene now those are very very rare
because we don't want people to have to
intervene in all circumstances
especially in instances like we saw with
an armed carjacking what were they
supposed to do they're presumably the
guy had a gun so the duty to rescue laws
exist but they are very very rare I know
that California does actually have a
variation on a duty to rescue law it's
not a duty to rescue and certainly
nothing like what you're seeing in
Seinfeld but it is a duty to report in
the wake of some of the reports of child
abuse and child endangerment California
passed a law that said that you had to
report certain crimes being committed
against a child under the age of
14 but even there it's not a felony to
fail to report the crime it is I think a
misdemeanor and a fine of 1500 or $2,000
there's no way that you're likely going
to have an American law somewhere that
says it is a major felony up to five
years in jail to fail to intervene in
another felony being committed who told
you to put the cheese off did I tell you
to put the cheese on I didn't tell you
to put the cheese on you people with the
cheese
it never ends hello mm-hmm mm-hmm mm-hmm
so this guy's clearly like Johnny Connor
in law I never heard of you don't have
to help anybody
yeah country's all about this lawyer is
right unfathomable improbable Oh No
Susie guess um I put him with dr. bison
in a pack a bag for me I want to get to
Latham Massachusetts right away
nice so you know clearly a lawyer who is
in the mold of the famous Johnnie
Cochran who has passed away but was well
known for being OJ Simpson's attorney
I probably would have had a very similar
reaction to that phone call that that's
a ridiculous law that doesn't exist
anywhere in reality we'd probably be
right number two doesn't matter if your
clients in jail you get out of your
office and you go to your client and you
deal with whatever kind of local
nonsense is is going on so yeah I kind
of like kind of like that lawyer
character so they got Jackie child huh
you know what that means
so a place is going to be swarming with
medium with time this thing is over
you're not gonna be able to find a hotel
room in this town
astute legal eagles will recognize that
character actor whose name escapes me at
the moment but he was the expert witness
in my cousin Vinnie talking about the
tire marks that were made in front of
the sack of suds so it's good to see
that he got promoted from expert witness
to local district attorney the whole
country is going to be watching this now
we got a decent I think you see the same
accent too in it no matter what the cost
not a big issue
trial is going to be character mmm that
is absolutely not true
character actually is figuratively the
least important thing in a criminal
trial and in fact the prosecution
doesn't even have the option to bring in
character evidence in a situation like
this force district Kali court Latham
Massachusetts is now in session the
Honorable Judge Arthur Vandelay
presiding the judges name is Van Doren
Amanda whoo Church Janet
yeah I think that's a good sign is the
district attorney ready to proceed we
are your honor
so are we starting trial here they've
just totally skipped the indictment the
arraignment all the pretrial exchange of
material Brady disclosures
investigations I mean you know it's a
comedy I know no one's gonna want to
watch all the procedural stuff this
isn't Law & Order and even then they
will skip through everything but man
this appears to be happening all on the
same day so that's that's a little
unrealistic there ladies and gentlemen
last year our City Council by a vote of
12 to 2 passed a Good Samaritan Law now
essentially we made it a crime to ignore
a fellow human being in trouble now this
grooves about wrong New York not only
ignored but as we will prove they
actually mocked the victim as he was
being robbed at gunpoint I can guarantee
you one other thing ladies and gentlemen
this is not the first time they have
behaved in this manner go objection
improper character argument of mocking
and maligning this is a history of
selfishness self-absorption
immaturity and greed how everyone who is
come into contact with these four
individuals has been abused wrong
deceived and betrayed that is completely
improper the American system recognizes
that just because you have acted in a
certain way in the past under different
circumstances that doesn't mean that you
are going to act in conformity with that
character on a
in instance generally speaking criminal
defendants never have to face the burden
of overcoming the prosecution entering
in bad character evidence because the
prosecution is never allowed to bring in
character evidence against the accused
because it's just not simply relevant I
mean we can as regular people recognize
that it might be relevant in an abstract
sense but we have decided as a society
that it is not relevant for the purposes
of a court hearing now there is an
exception in that the defendant has the
option to bring in evidence of good
character if you're simply saying that
they are such a good person that they
couldn't possibly have committed it well
that option resides with the criminal
defendants and when you do that you open
the floodgates and then the prosecution
is allowed to rebut evidence of good
character with evidence of bad character
but you're not allowed to gild the lily
and say not only did they commit this
specific act or in this case an omission
but they're also bad people you're not
allowed to do that so the rest of it is
is just complete nonsense
I am shocked and chagrined and it's very
much like Johnnie Cochran I love it
this trial is outrageous it is a waste
of the taxpayers time and money it is a
travesty of justice that these four
people have been incarcerated while the
real perpetrator is walking around lap
lion and lapping lapping and lion I love
it you might remember that Johnnie
Cochran the real attorney was famous for
these alliterative phrases that he would
use in court and often people derided
that as being childish but it's a little
brilliance in trial because there are a
million things that are going on and it
is so important to allow the jury to
hang their hat on something and to be
able to get through the jury and give
them something simple a theme or a
phrase that you can hammer home at every
turn it's definitely good trial practice
so I kind of like what he's doing he's
shocked and chagrined do you know what
these four people were they were
innocent bystanders that turn in
they stay innocent bystanders
because that's exactly what they were we
know they were bystanders nobody's
disputing that so how can a bystander be
guilty no such thing have you ever heard
of a guilty bystander
no because you cannot be a bystander and
be guilty bystanders are by definition
innocent that is the nature of bystander
and that is a great summary of the
status quo of American law absolutely
right
innocent bystanders are by definition
innocent in the absence of this crazy
Massachusetts law that doesn't actually
exist that's a hundred percent accurate
is the prosecution ready to present its
first witness we are your honor
call officer Matt Vogel to the stand all
right Matt Vogel so the police officer
is not a character witness this guy
would absolutely be allowed to testify
because he was a percipient witness to
what happened did one of them have a
video camera
yes your honor with the court's
permission we would like to playback
that video and enter it into evidence is
exhibit a seat I mean they haven't
established the proper chain of custody
they're generally records that are
created outside of court qualifies here
safe regardless of the fact that it is a
recording it's still considered a
statement for the purposes of the
hearsay rule but given that it was taken
by the defendants arguably that is an
admission by a party or a statement of a
party so it's probably proper for that
to come in
assuming proper chain of custody is made
which the police officer should
establish but just because you're a bad
person doesn't mean you committed a
crime and arguably if I was the defense
attorney here I might stipulate to the
fact that it's unfairly prejudicial for
the audio to be played because it's not
relevant to their actions you can see
from the tape that they did not help
this person who was being carjacked but
the things that they are saying are so
unfairly prejudicial
that it outweighs the probative value of
the statements that are actually being
made and you know it's unfair character
evidence to come in so I think that the
attorneys here really should have made
an objection and fought over the at
least the audio portion of that tape
call Mabel Choate to the stand
call Mabel Choate who who is this person
you're on I'm most strenuously and
vigorously object to this witness she
was not present at the time of the
incident her testimony is irrelevant
irrational and inconsequential yep 100
percent great objection has gone to
great lengths and considerable cost to
find these character witnesses it is
imperative that we establishes is not
merely an isolated incident it's part of
a pattern of any social behavior that's
been going on for years no objection
overruled
I'll hear the witness yeah so just
because the prosecution goes to great
expense to find a witness that has
nothing to do with whether that witness
can actually testify at court the judge
here is supposed to act like a
gatekeeper and keep out unfair
extraneous evidence like this now mrs.
Cho would you please tell the court what
happened the evening of January 4th I
was in sister's bakery when I got
accosted by that man what did he want my
marble rye not admissible funny vehicle
for the finale but totally improper from
a trial perspective I dated mr. Seinfeld
for several weeks in the autumn of 1992
then an evening of October 28th there
was an abrupt end of that relationship
tell us what happened the four of them
made a wager to see who could go the
longest without gratifying themselves
okay
improper character witness pursuit it's
Moops also improper character witness
mr. Kramer gave you a used wheelchair
that's right
not relevant so she pretended to trip
and she fell into your breasts he sent
her in there to find out if they were
real not admissible it was a communist
now she exposed her nipple mm-hmm
Cynthia told me to change the menu to
Pakistani but nobody came uh a proper
character cockfighting cook baiting
improper character she tried to smother
me with a pillow
improper character well I invited him to
attend my son's birthday party a bravura
character Oh charlie horse jeez this
courtroom and everyone who's attended
this trial is still reeling from the
endless parade of witnesses who've come
forth so enthusiastically to testify
against these four seemingly ordinary
people one even had the feeling that if
judge Vandelay didn't finally put a stop
to it
it could have gone on for months so this
is why you don't allow irrelevant
character witnesses
regardless of the expense of the
prosecution and finding all of these
people it just it never ends it's a
parade of people who really can't answer
the question of whether the defendants
committed the act that they are accused
of in this specific instance they might
be horrible people but it has no
relevance to their criminal prosecution
so all this is improper Oh
moving on
[Music]
so does the defense not get to make a
closing statement here we're just going
straight to jury deliberation
well the defendants please rise and how
do you find with respect to the charge
of criminal indifference we find the
defendants guilty well I mean as the
crime was laid out they were guilty of
it it's just the law that is stupid and
should not be on the books I do not know
how or under what circumstances the four
of you found each other but your callous
indifference and utter disregard for
everything that is good and decent has
wrought the very foundation upon which
our society is built I can think of
nothing more fitting and for the four of
you to spend a year removed from society
so that you can contemplate the manner
in which you have conducted yourselves
so in real life there would be a
separate sentencing hearing in most
places there are guidelines that you
have to follow to make sure that there
aren't manifestly unjust sentences that
are brought down you wouldn't have the
sentencing hearing immediately following
the actual guilt portion of the trial
because there are all kinds of other
factors that go into how much of a
sentence they get the judge here is
decided here on a maximum of five years
whereas you know you're gonna have to
take into account a lot of different
kinds of evidence than what was elicited
at the actual initial trial so that
would take place weeks or months later
there would be probably an immediate
appeal given the ridiculous number of
character witnesses that were called in
which was clearly unjust and unduly
prejudicial and yeah this conviction is
totally gonna get overturned on appeal
[Music]
okay that was the series finale of
Seinfeld funnier than I remember I might
have to actually go back and watch a few
more episodes of Seinfeld because maybe
I just couldn't appreciate it when I was
a younger man but now it's time to give
Seinfeld a grade for legal realism on
one hand you have a discussion of laws
that kind of exist in some circumstances
there's no such thing as criminal and
difference that I'm aware of in any US
jurisdiction maybe in France but there
are duty to report laws and so there are
sometimes duties that are imputed to
individuals who would otherwise be an
innocent bystander and I really like the
character of Jackie childs he is a
simulacrum of Johnnie Cochran same
initials same litigation style it's a
little cartoonish but also indicative of
some really good trial practice in there
as well on the other hand you have
dozens of improper witnesses you have a
law that would not exist in real life so
the whole premise for the show is thrown
into question and you have a timeline
where they are convicted of a major
felony in the span of 48 hours maybe so
oh no I'm going to have to give the
finale of Seinfeld
a d-plus for realism no soup for you
like that's it that's a Seinfeld thing
right nothing for you
now if you liked Seinfeld which is a
story about nothing
you'll love the documentaries on
curiosity stream which are stories about
something one film I've really been
enjoying ever since I did a review of
Star Trek The Next Generation is called
Trek nation it's all about the history
of Star Trek and Gene Roddenberry as
told by his son
it's about Star Trek but it's also the
story of what it's like to be the
rebellious non Trekkie son of Gene
Roddenberry and Majel Barret and how he
came to understand why Star Trek means
so much to so many people there are tons
of interviews with the people that made
Star Trek what it is today like Ronald D
Moore Jonathan Frakes you display this
as a trophy
a pet give a sweet tooth and JJ Abrams's
so if you want a documentary that is
actually about something you've got to
check out curiosity stream legal eagles
get a free account for 30 days by
clicking the link below or by using the
promo code legal eagle using the promo
code really helps out this channel so
click on the link below and get
curiosity stream for free
I bet Jerry in the game would really
like to watch all of the award-winning
documentaries on curiosity stream while
they spend the next year in jail for
criminal indifference I don't think it's
that bad do you agree leave your
objections in the comments and check out
my other real lawyer reactions over here
where I will see you in court